much-awaited every week it is time for
hatred mail it's like a mandatory
transvaginal ultrasound for your mind
Patriot Man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman yep because America and
because freedom
this week's hatred mail hits many of the
buzz words of alt right
trumpets troll speak as I like to call
it 1984 by George Orwell brought us
double speak and double think now we
have troll speak let's take a listen to
this week's hatred mail go yourself I
don't like him as a Republican for being
gay and leaning to the right I like him
for what you just said I didn't his
ideas beliefs and his don't give up in
my own person attitude you're just a
liberal cook bro also we was interested
because we knew the UK was leaning
rights as well he owes you [ __ ] do you
have any idea what this Patriot mail is
about I couldn't understand any of that
is MIT and the him there is Donald Trump
yeah yeah yeah but I but I assume I've
never heard the assertion that Trump is
gay though from anyone especially from
someone who is explaining why they like
Trump is that there's something oh you
know what this this might be about Milo
this might be about Milo you nah poloz
can you put just the text on the screen
for a second like I'm curious now if we
interpret this as being about Milo you
nah police rather than Trump it might
make more sense maybe we can't put it
back up on the screen that's okay there
it is I don't like a czar okay so what
this person this is amazing I think in
real time we're interpreting what this
means this person is saying as a
Republican as a Republican they don't
like Milo because Milo is gay and leans
to the right they like him for reasons
that I said this this person didn't like
Milo I I'm barely even making sense
bicep mutt myself but I think that the
point here is Milo is popular with this
hatred
not because he is a gay Republican but
for other reasons that was some
on-the-spot investigative journalism
right there and we got to the bottom and
I think we did get to the bottom of this
remember you can turn hate reott mail
into something positive for the David
Pakman show we have a coupon code it's
hey tree at 40 all one word all
lowercase H atri ot for zero it'll save
you 40% off of membership at david
pakman.com slash membership